[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
21 octobre 2016 bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission
pour revenir sur l'actualité de la
semaine voici les titres nicolas
dupont-aignan le président de debout la
france et candidat déclaré à la
présidentielle était il ya embrouillé
dans les yvelines pour une réunion
publique le député de l'essonne en a
profité pour dévoiler quelques-uns de
ses soutiens dans le département
jean-pierre sevestre maire de coignières
et vice président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge des
sports sera notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission nous allons évoquer avec
lui bien sûr les championnats d'europe
de cyclisme sur piste qui se tient en ce
moment à saint quentin mais aussi la
ryder cup et les jeux olympiques de 2022
24 dans le reste de l'actualité
nous reviendrons sur la colère des
policiers qui monte depuis l'agression
de plusieurs agents en banlieue
parisienne il ya deux semaines encore la
fibre optique qui arriva voisins le
bretonneux
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
on ouvre ce journal avec de la politique
et nicolas dupont aignan candidat de
debout la france et candidat à la
présidentielle qui tenait hier une
réunion publique à rambouillet devant 80
personnes
il a présenté ses propositions pour le
pays et fait le point sur ses soutiens
dans les yvelines reportage de nicolas
d'andré
nicolas dupont aignan est venu chasser
sur les terres de jean frédéric poisson
en meeting à rambouillet il a voulu
rassembler ses militants yvelinois et
attirer de nouveaux adhérents à son
mouvement debout la france est un parti
qui progresse dans les yvelines aux
élections régionales nous avons fait un
gros score puisque j'ai la liste que je
conduisais a fait près de 6 et demi pour
cent au niveau régional et un bon score
dans les yvelines donc nous progressons
la venue d'un candidat à la
présidentielle à rambouillet a attiré
des curieux ainsi que des militants de
longue date rallier à la cause de son
parti en tant que citoyen français sur
sa naturelle de s'intéresser aux
différents présidentiable et à partir de
là c'était important pour moi de
rencontrer une des personnes qui s'y
présente dont nicolas dupont aignan je
suis pas forcément convaincu parce que
il a bien préparé son programme sauf que
pour moi ce jeu quand même le sentiment
que le fait qu'il n'ait pas été ministre
qui n'est pas exercer des activités à la
tête de l'état c'est quand même un
handicap sa lucidité ça m'a toujours
épaté son bon sens
son honnêteté présent au meeting de
nicolas dupont aignan philippe brillault
il a récemment démissionné de son poste
de conseiller départemental et se
retrouve dans certaines propositions du
candidat
aujourd'hui si je viens d'écouter ce
n'est pas pour autant que je suis là
pour adhérer je suis là pour écouter et
pour l'encourager moi j'ai trouvé qu'il
y avait beaucoup de bonnes idées qui
était partagée par beaucoup voilà je
trouve que c'est intéressant d'écouter
tout le monde prochaine étape pour
nicolas dupont aignan rassemblé 500
parrainages d'élus locaux ou nationaux
avant la date butoir fixée courant mars
sport à présent avec l'inauguration hier
de la rue laurent fignon à proximité du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le cycliste français double vainqueur du
tour de france dans les années 80 est
décédé il y a 6 ans l'inauguration de la
rue s'est faite en présence notamment de
valérie fignon sa femme et du secrétaire
d'état chargé aux sports thierry
braillard qui a tenu à saluer la mémoire
d'un grand champion on les écoute il me
semble que c'est un choix important
c'est un choix que je partage temps
laurent fignon a marqué le cyclisme
français mais au delà
khadir a marqué le sport français
c'était émouvant parce que c'est un
champion qui n'a pas laissé indifférent
puis il ya des champions qui dans la
différentes disciplines vont gagner des
titres et puis quel temps après on s'en
souvient plus là vous rendez compte plus
de vingt ans après on se souvient encore
de la façon dont laurent fignon a gagné
sept tours de france a été gagné le tour
d'italie a gagné milan san remo c'était
un grand champion car puce avait une
personnalité très facile pour le peloton
parfois mais j'avais dire si la race des
grands champions
il avait quelque chose de plus que les
autres et c'est peut-être aussi pour
cela que on avait cette émotion mais
aussi peut-être aussi pour cela que la
commune de montigny le bretonneux a
naturellement choisi de rang fignon pour
appeler la rue qui efface au vélodrome
nationale et cette inauguration s'est
fait bien sûr en plein championnat
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
résultats les derniers résultats des
français avec une nouvelle médaille d'or
et hier c'est de la poursuite par équipe
masculine les quatre français ont battu
les italiens en finale c'est la
troisième médaille pour le camp
tricolore depuis le début de la
compétition mercredi les championnats
d'europe se déroule jusqu'à dimanche
soir au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
[Musique]
et pour évoquer à présent maintenant
l'actualité de la semaine jean pierre
sauvestre nous a rejoint sur le plateau
bonsoir bonsoir jean pierre sauvestre
vous êtes le maire sans étiquette de
coignières et vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge des sports
forcément vous aimez le sport c'est une
logique ça faisait ça vous évoque quoi à
titre personnel le nom de laurent fignon
quand vous venez de voir cette interview
et et ce mini reportage heures à vous
c'est quoi des souvenirs lelong laurent
fignon ce sont c'est une personne qui
m'évoque des souvenirs de mon époque de
vélo parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
vélo j'ai fait beaucoup de cyclisme non
pas en compétition mais en tant que
cyclotouristes et notamment paris brest
paris et c'est ce sont des épreuves qui
m'ont beaucoup plu et laurent fignon
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai soutenu au
cours de sa carrière c'est quelqu'un qui
avait un courage énorme et c'est
quelqu'un également qu'il y avait une
stratégie de course particules
particulière particulière mais c'est
vrai que l'événement autour se terminant
sur les champs elysées avec une
différence de vie secondes c'est ce qui
m'avait
beaucoup marqué pour ce qui concerne
laurent fignon et quelle déception pour
lui effectivement mais quel grand
champion ce avec sa tour de france à
tours d'italie ça manque selon vous des
champions comme ça français on va dire
un peu hors du sol qui sont pas dans les
on va dire papa banal actuellement nous
avons effectivement une période où nous
avons des recherches de champion qui ne
sont pas oui c'est vrai qu'ils ne
courent pas d'une façon pas très pas
très pradines et ordinaire je dirais
c'est vrai et puis nous avons énormément
de mal aussi bien sûr à
avoir des champions qui qui arrivent
dans des courses par étapes par exemple
à se démarquer nous avons énormément de
mal actuellement mais je pense que nous
allons avec nos directeurs techniques
nationaux nous allons réussir à faire
quelque chose alors je vais aussi ses
ornements les championnats d'europe se
déroule au vélodrome de saint quentin
depuis mercredi mais vous vous êtes
rendus sur place c'est une belle fête
pour le moment comment ça se passe quel
regard vous portez sur ces championnats
d'europe
comme un amateur de vélo je porte un
regard particulier sur ces championnats
d'europe c'est une organisation qui est
très très rôdée et avec de très très
grands champs si vous aviez la question
j'en avais enfin le vélodrome avait
accueilli les championnats du
championnat du monde en 2015 c'est vrai
que je n'avais pas encore la charge de
la vice présidence chargée des sports
c'est la manière dont vous c'est une
première en tant que socialiste en tant
que politique sur place c'est vrai mais
j'avais suivi bien sûr les championnats
du monde 2015 avec un taux d'intérêt et
c'est une grande fête c'est une grande
fête du vélo et avec un équipement tel
que nous avons l'ordre national c'est
extraordinaire en plus les français font
des plutôt bons résultats c'est
important ça que le pays hôte face des
bons résultats pour pour que la fête
soit on va dire à son comble sinon ça
gâche un peu on va dire le fait bien sûr
bien sûr c'est très important cette
phase importante les champions locaux je
dirais le fasse des performances et nous
avons avec la victoire poursuite hier
nous avons quelque chose qui nous qui
nous remonte un peu le moral par rapport
aux résultats au jour dans la région
olympiques de rio
au mois d'août dernier petit bémol tout
de même l'affluence on est loin de
remplir le vélodrome comme comme aux
mondiaux est ce que c'est qu'une
surprise pour vous alors vous le saviez
vous vous en doutiez notamment peut-être
à cause des résultats qui joue sur eder
sur le moral sur leurs rides découvre
ici tient certainement il ya
certainement le moral et les champions
peut-être qu'ils qui ont un peu déçu à
rio et qui empêche peut-être l'affluence
sur ces championnats d'europe mais il
faut aussi tenir compte des événements
qui peuvent aussi freiner certaines
personnes haut placées dans des
événements un peu en foule si vous
pensez à la crainte d'attaqués
terroristes voilà c'est ça je pense un
petit peu sur le sur le vélodrome mais
nous avons depuis mercredi effectivement
une affluence qui est qui réduite il
faut préciser mais nous avons maintenant
ce soir qu'il y aura deux vendredi soir
puis samedi minimum le week end ont misé
sur le week end bien sûr accueillir
beaucoup plus de monde globalement
depuis depuis son inauguration 2014 le
vélodrome a du mal à se remplir mise à
part au championnat du monde on le
disait c'est vrai ce que c'est quelque
chose que à laquelle vous réfléchissez
vous est très lucide quand ça pour
savoir comment on peut remplir ce
vélodrome pluvieuse ans bien sûr c'est
une navette est il qu'une préoccupation
effectivement par des événements compte
tenu d
de la capacité de ses 5es places à peu
près à peu près 5 mai le 1500 puis sur
le central en matière de centrales sur
leur central on peut accueillir
effectivement mais si nous arrivons déjà
accueillir 3000 4000 personnes
régulièrement ségolène nous serions déjà
dans une position un peu plus favorable
et du coup vous souhaitez organiser quoi
des concerts des événements des
hauts-de-seine sexuellement autres que
sportifs mais sportif également bien sûr
c'est un équipement qui est tout de même
destinée aux vélos
cyclisme / quand on le voit quand on s'y
rend on comprend que oscillant comprend
l'ambiance etc mais je pense
qu'effectivement il faut organiser soi
des concerts des événements
remarquables au sein de cet équipement
je pense qu'on peut faire des choses
remarque anne en tout cas si le
vélodrome peinent à se remplir parfois
les commerces alentour eux ont le
sourire restaurants et hôtels voient
leur fréquentation augmenter
considérablement pendant les grandes
compétitions reportage à ce propos de
patrick jacques de dixmude et osman
vendeurs des tous les athlètes se sont
préparés pour l'événement mais pas
seulement les commerces cinquantaine ont
dû aussi préparer l'arrivée des
visiteurs et des athlètes comme à
l'hôtel ibis situé juste à côté du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui a dû adapter ses repas au niveau de
la restauration en tout cas des menus
adaptés à munich et en tel sportif sur
le restaurant myssyk l'heure ce qui est
située dans le même bâtiment que d'hôtel
donc des repas sportif de pâtes
blanc play de dinde en tout cas tout
pour garantir le meilleur niveau de
performance pendant cette compétition du
19 jusqu'au 23 octobre l'hôtel est
complet ce qui représente environ 1200
chambres mais il n'ya pas que les hôtels
qui attendre l'arrivée des sportifs les
restaurants aussi comme le bistrot du
théâtre à montigny le bretonneux qui est
prêt à les accueillir nous on est un
établissement qui fonctionne
relativement complet donc on est on a
toujours une une heureuse de deux ou
trois jours d'avant son stock et là
évidemment on a renforcé sur les
produits notamment les pâtes les choses
comme ça qui les sportifs prennent
beaucoup quoi durant les championnats
d'europe le bistrot du théâtre envisage
une augmentation de son chiffre
d'affaires de 15% les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste se
déroule du 19 au 23 octobre 2016
jean pierre sauvestre envoyait un tel
événement c'est aussi bon pour
l'économie locale c'est aussi pour ça
que qu'un politique que l'agglomération
se bat pour avoir des événements
importants c'est pour les alentours les
commerces locaux bien sûr bien sûr
économiquement je pense qu'il est
intéressant d'avoir des événements de
taille européenne de taille mondiale
mondiale et pour les bien sûr pour
l'hébergement pour la restauration mais
pas seulement je pense que c'est de la
connaissance aussi du territoire de
saint quentin pour l'avenir je pense
qu'il est indispensable d'accueillir des
grands événements tels que les
championnats vous vous attendez
d'ailleurs des retombées précis c'est ce
que vous avez des chiffres précis ou
alors des attentes ou alors vous dites
là on verra de à cause du contexte
compliqué dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure voilà tout à fait à cause du
contexte particulier que nous avons
actuellement en france je pense que les
retombées vont être très intéressante
mais je pense qu'actuellement nous
n'avons pas de chiffres précis je ne
peux pas vous donner de chiffres sur les
retombées économiques effectives alors
en termes de grandes compétitions 50 ans
ne sera pas en reste puisque dans deux
ans on va accueillir ou plutôt
l'agglomération va accueillir la fameuse
la ryder cup la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde l'a clairement on est
un cran au dessus c'est une autre
influence une autre attente quelque
chose que l'agglomération attend
beaucoup plus dire même est assez
important les championnats d'or de ses
clips bien sûr des championnats d'europe
de cyclisme de cyclisme sont importants
mais la ryder cup c'est le troisième
événement sportif un mondial après
effectivement le championnat du monde de
foot de football et puis les jeux
olympiques et la ryder cup
2016 qui s'est déroulé déroulé quelques
années à côté de minneapolis il ya
quelques temps à accueillir accueilli
journellement entre 50000 les 70000
spectateurs sur le parcours sur trois
jours on peut s'attendre à deux cent
mille personnes qui vont venir à saint
quentin voilà je pense qu'on peut
s'attendre à deux cent mille personnes
sur trois quatre jours à saint quentin
effectivement et pour les accueillir il
est bien il va falloir effectivement
prévoir les infrastructures et les
transports et l'hébergement c'est ce que
je dirai ces économies ils vont être
très importants j'allais vous de vous
poser cette question vous vous êtes
rendu aux états unis pour l'édition 2016
qui vient de se conclure
comment est l'ambiance ça va s que
c'était impressionnant pour vous parce
que forcément vous étiez en repérage
s'il ya des choses que vous avez capté
vous à les ramener ici à saint quentin
oui effectivement le le parcours de golf
aux états unis amènent une ambiance une
ambiance beaucoup plus festive que qu'en
europe là le l'ambiance aux etats unis
c'est une ambiance beaucoup plus
populaires séné barbecue c'est cette
voie là c'est laisser la fête alors
qu'en france on a le but à l'image d'un
sport élitiste voilà se tenir à bien pas
faire de bruit pas faire de bruit
effectivement ce qui ce qui peut se
comprendre soi mais tout à fait tout ça
fait parce que on peut constater que les
grands champions font des choses
extraordinaires
en golf et c'est une ambiance vraiment
extraordinaire et si nous arrivons à me
porter cette ambiance en france
partiellement effectivement puisque les
américains viendront en nombre même
avoir ce mourad a hérité un aliment il
aura beaucoup d'européens mais je pense
qu'effectivement ça apportera d'abord la
connaissance du golfe et je pense que la
ryder cup n'était pas connu énormément
il y a même 4 5 ans par rapport à ce
qu'elle ait connu a tellement et je
pense les retombées économiques seront
très importantes à partir de 2018 non
seulement sur le territoire de 50 ans
avec le golf national mais également sur
l'île de france bien sûr mais également
pour la france en retombées touristiques
est ce que le golf national aujourd'hui
en 2016 en octobre 2016 serait prêt à
accueillir la ryder cup ou alors ya
encore des choses à modifier les travaux
vous parliez de travaux tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que ce soit encore amélioré
pour ce match on ira de l'avant sur le
parcours se sait en et hors le parcours
de l'albatros et terry leahy terminé et
prêt pour la ryder cup 2018 mais ce sont
des aménagements des aménagements pour
accueillir je dire la logistique refaire
les routes a grandi ressources de places
de parking le plus de places de parkings
créés des navettes effectivement avec la
gare de saint-quentin créer des
transports supplémentaires des trains
supplémentaires également il ya toute
cette infrastructure et cette
organisation à mettre en place ça va
être un coup excusez moi ça va être un
coût important pour l'agglomération
c'est les critiques on peut aussi
parfois entendre sur un tel événement
c'est très bien ça va ramener du monde
ça va faire connaître quelques semaines
elle très ça coûte de l'argent si ça
coûte de l'argent qui je n'ai pas à me
le chiffre là je peux pas vous donner ce
chiffre actuellement vous auriez dû me
le demandez un peu
on attend deux cent mille personnes sur
trois jours 1200 journalistes accrédités
saint quentin en yvelines va être connu
dans le monde entier aux états unis
voilà aux états unis bien sûr bien sûr
comme je pense que eisenstein également
qui accueillit la ryder cup cette année
il connut aussi mondialement maintenant
et puis en plus du coût de la ryder cup
vous n'avez pas manqué de travail en
tant que vice président en charge des
sports puisque vous travaillez déjà sur
l'éventualité d'une candidature devant
bien sûr paris accueille plutôt léger ou
2024 là il y aurait la colline
d'elancourt le vélodrome le golf
national pour vous c'est j'imagine vous
êtes le vice-président en charge des
sports le plus chanceux de france oui
peut-être et peut-être deux depuis très
longtemps effectivement parce que si
nous arrivons à accueillir ces jeux
olympiques 2024 ce que j'espère est
d'ailleurs je porte déjà le pubis 28
voilà
je pense que ce sera une chose
extraordinaire les lettres de garantie
sur nos installations ont été transmises
au comité olympique
cela veut dire comme des valeurs nobles
et à dire que nous avons une structure
seront disponibles seront disponibles
pour les jeux olympiques en 2024 dans le
reste de l'actualité à présent la colère
des policiers qui manifestent depuis
plusieurs jours après l'agression de
quatre de leurs collègues et il y a deux
semaines dans l'essonne les policiers
dénoncent notamment le manque de moyens
et un dysfonctionnement de la justice la
semaine dernière sur ce plateau même
nous avions reçu d'ailleurs le
représentant syndical du syndicat
alliance de la police alliance c'était
julien le cam on les écoute
depuis une dizaine d'années sur le
département on voit que les effectifs de
police diminuent dangereusement 1
actuellement des petites structures de
police sont fermés sur le département
effectivement quand vous voyez les
effectifs de votre commissariat diminué
d'année en année les moyens diminuent
également c'est vrai que ce sont pas
forcément des gestes qu'on attend de la
part nos élus nos politiques en
attendant des moyens vous disiez avant
cet entretien en l'espace de dix ans le
département des yvelines a perdu à peu
près 300 fonctionnaires de police et ça
c'est ça actuellement on est en train de
fermer des commissariats a envoyé le
commissariat de vélizy va être fermé par
manque d'effectif il y à une
restructuration des services qui a été
effectué il ya trois ans par manque
d'effectif donc on a tout simplement
regrouper les effectifs dans des
agglomérations les sons des
commissariats à l'abandon sur le
département jean-pierre sevestre quel
regard vous portez sur ces
manifestations de policiers ils
expriment un sentiment d'abandon vous le
ressentez vous aussi vous qui êtes mère
et qu'il y avait du coup à faire parfois
aux forces de police pas forcément vous
personnellement monsieur personnellement
bien sûr non nous avons besoin des
forces de police bien sûr et pour un
maire s'appuyer sur la police nationale
c'est essentiel et par exemple le désert
dont on parlait à l'instant qui était
évoquée par julien le calme est ce que
vous le vous le sentez vous à coignières
alors nous n'avons nous ne sentons pas
un désert à coignières parce que nous
avons le commissariat d'elancourt
effectivement qui est un qui est une
aide énorme pour la commune de
coignières mais nous avons besoin
également d'une police municipale et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
délibéré il y a quelques mois maintenant
pour la création la recréation je dirais
parce que c'est un service qui avait été
abandonné il y a quelques années pour la
re création d'un service de police
municipale composée de six agents en
civil pour permettre de faire la police
de proximité j'allais vous dire
justement pourquoi recréer une police
municipale elle va combler un manque de
sécurité un manque de de coire pourquoi
elle va m'en elle va combler un manque
de proximité par rapport à la population
par rapport aux besoins de sécurité qui
éprouvent également nos administrés bien
sûr avec les événements c'est bien
évident mais avec également parfois les
incivilités qui ce qui se ne viennent
récemment tipi avec le temps
nous n'avons pas encore si vous voulez
sur coignières une insécurité qui puisse
être signalé particulière mais nous
avons besoin justement d'avoir 7
ce service de police municipale pour
nous permettre d'assurer une sécurité
dans le temps et puis dans le magazine
municipal s'est inscrit ses préventions
avant verbalisation c'est ça la police
municipale oui la police municipale
actuellement ses préventions avant
verbalisation mais effectivement nous
serons peut être amenés peut-être à
verbaliser pour les personnes qui ne
comprendrait pas très bien cette
prévention l'arrivée des agents à
coignières c'est pourquoi précisément
vous avez une date précise en attaque
précise c'est difficile parce que le
recrutement d'agents municipaux de
policiers municipaux c'est une chose
très importante
le recrutement d'un agent municipal
c'est important mais un policier
municipal c'est d'autant plus important
nous sommes actuellement sur le
recrutement du policier municipal chargé
de constituer son équipe et lorsque nous
aurons recruté sept personnes ce qui
doit se
être effectués dans l'est dans les
semaines à venir dans les deux trois
semaines nous compléterons ensuite
l'équipe j'irai dans les trois quatre
mois à venir et j'irai au cours du
premier semestre
2007 nous aurons une police municipale
complète dernière question est très
rapidement une réponse très rapide
certains de vos collègues notamment l
encours songe armée la police municipale
est-ce que vous en êtes déjà cette étape
là ou alors ce sera éventuellement pour
plus tard mais pour l'instant déjà au
créer une police municipale vous savez
bon on dira je ne dirai jamais jamais
jamais ce n'est pas possible mais avant
d'en arriver armée une police je pense
qu'il faut connaître ses agents il faut
connaître les personnes qui porteront
les les armes mais lorsqu'on parle
armement il y à toutes sortes
d'armements aussi il ya bien sûr les les
pistolets à impulsion électrique il ya
effectivement et les revolvers et
pistolets vraiment avec des conséquences
très très importante et actuellement
nous ne sommes pas dans cette étape
d'armement du tout nous sommes dans
l'étape de recrutement de personnes qui
soient à la disposition de nos
administrés pour assure une sécurité
complet ou presque mercredi jacques
attali et étaient invités à participer à
une conférence sur le campus yvelinois
d' hec l'ancien conseiller spécial de
françois mitterrand a notamment évoqué
sa vision de la france et donner son
point de vue sur les enjeux pour 2017
reportage
priorité à l'éducation à l'europe ou à
la lutte contre les inégalités jacques
attali a une vision précise du monde et
de la france une vision qu'il a exposée
durant plus d'une heure devant un
amphithéâtre plein
l'économiste et écrivain consulté par
tous les présidents de la république est
revenu notamment sur la prochaine
campagne présidentielle avec ironie
l'europe va l'europe
la licité comment
la formation des chômeurs jeunes et
passive 5 est pour moi absolument majeur
la formation des chômeurs c'est là
qu'est donc on ne parle pas de leur
sujet et donc forcément le prochain
président de comme les trois précédents
jeux chirac puis sarkozy et hollande ont
été élus avec un mandat explicite ne
rien faire
et ils ont par
le fondateur de l'organisation
humanitaire action contre la faim a
surtout exposé sa vision pour le long
terme lui qui estime que la france peut
être la grande puissance du 21e siècle
un propos convaincants pour ses
auditeurs d'un soir je pense que c'était
un débat oui très très constructif et
qui nous aiderait je pense que les
étudiants h essais à aborder l'avenir
avec certaines ce qui m'a marqué c'est
de me dire qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise
comme burke on voit qu'avec un peu un
poussin et en arabe ce que ça va devenir
un truc énorme dit qu'en fait ça va tout
va tellement vite que c'est déjà en
train de en train de disparaître et
jacques attali risque d'être une
nouvelle fois convoité à la proche des
présidentielles lui qui ne se reconnaît
pour le moment dans aucun candidat
jean-pierre sevestre une seule question
politique jacques attali ne se reconnaît
dans aucun candidat vous vous êtes
plutôt évidemment tendance droite
l'élu sans étiquette quel candidat vous
vous plaît le plus dans dans la primaire
en ce moment à le faire en ce moment
actuellement c'est alain juppé je pense
que c'est le candidat qui me semble le
plus raisonnable pour 2010 est
actuellement l'arrivée de la fibre
optique se précise pour voisins le
bretonneux les premiers travaux ont
débuté dans la combine dans la commune
annoncé par la mer alexandra rosetti
lors de ses voeux en janvier 2016 le
très haut débit pourrait débarquer chez
les premiers vie sinois l'an prochain
une réunion publique était d'ailleurs
organisée sur ce sujet mardi soir
mélanie poker j'espère simplement qu'ils
vont aller très vite parce que on attend
avec impatience d'avoir un peu plus de
débit on a un des pics très médiocre
depuis des années et on aurait bien
voulu avoir qu'un seul et même opérateur
et avoir la fibre quoi
rapidement très mauvais débit est très
très frais et surtout très intermittent
avec d une qualité très variable as a
service qui est d'assez mauvaise qualité
voilà le mauvais débit à voisin un
problème récurrent qui devrait bientôt
changer d'ici mars 2010 est les premiers
habitants pourront bénéficier de la
fibre nous avons installé concrètement
les armoires de mutualisation qui est un
petit peu le socle d'eau
du déploiement du ftth sur voisins le
bretonneux donc de la fibre optique
alors le premier lot qui est fait sur
2016 et qui s'étalera un peu sur 2017 me
correspond à peu près à 2000 logements
sur voisin le très haut débit permettra
aux vices ynwa de recevoir des données
numériques plus rapidement l'arrivée de
la fibre a été annoncée par la commune
en janvier de cette année lorsqu'on a on
a appris que peut-être il y avait une
possibilité pour l'arcep de lever le
lever le monopole sfr et numericable
nous sommes engouffrés dans la brèche
pour écrire et demander effectivement à
ce que orange puisse postuler aussi à
voisins c'est orange c'est le budget
d'orange voilà après ils vont donner
d'explications effectivement ce soir sur
comment après les particuliers peuvent
se raccorder et choisir l'opérateur
qu'il souhaite évidemment mais ça ne
représente aucun budget pour la commune
une fois toutes les installations
réalisées plus de 4000 foyers seront
connectés
la totalité de la commune devrait être
entièrement fibré d'ici 2020
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci
jean pierre sauvestre de nous avoir
accompagnés pendant une demi heure le
soir je rappelle que vous êtes le maire
de coignières et vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge des sports merci à
vous aussi de nous avoir suivis bon ok
on a tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]